hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the world Fisher random
championship it's the well it's day
three so the four classical games are
over Wesley is leading with a nine point
lead as he won three games in classical
time format and in the classical time
for mattawin is three points so here we
entered the rapid section is fifteen
minutes plus two seconds increments so
here they do have an increment and
Carlson cannot afford to lose a game so
he has to either well he can do some of
the game he can row some of the games
but he has to win games in order to get
back into the match and uh well the nine
points is just a lot to recover from
yeah so without further ado Magnus what
did the white pieces opens with Knight
to b3 Knight to b3 now with the idea
that what you could go for f4 as it
immediately comes with it with a threat
would be a nice idea but then black
would have the same idea for example
with f5 and a nice to be three just
covers a lot of the ideas so Knight to
b3 probably to the favorite moves with
f5 by Wesley now opening up the light
square bishop if the knight moves the
pollinate who will be a target with f3
by Magnus preparing e4 and now Knight
the b6 with E for by Magnus we have
trade captures captures and now II five
and knights to e3 now we have Knights
the e6 by Wesley so a bit of a
symmetrical position c3 procuring d4 and
Bishop to g5 now we have Bishop to c2
and now a queenside castle Magnus does
the same we have a queenside castle and
Bishop to f7 now are preparing to get
this bishop into the game via Bishop to
h5 as the rockin d1 is a bit well it's
it's awkwardly placed so King the b1 by
Magnus and now Bishop to h5 attacking
the rook rook back to c1 as Magnus made
the room for the rook and now rook to f8
getting the rook to the only open file
on the board
and Magnus goes for h4 attacks the
bishop and now Wesley goes for Bishop
captures and III with bishop characters
and now Knight to f4 just getting that
Knight into the game
Magnus is still with the bishop pair and
he goes for rook to g1 the it seems like
he's a missing Knight to e2 which would
come with a fork but his idea after
night TV 2 is actually best from g5
which wins the D exchange back so it's
not a problem
so here Wesley doesn't allow also after
I - you could go for g4 first and then
rush up to g5 so here West plays the
very interesting Bishop to g4 he doesn't
allow Magnus to push at the g4 pawn and
now Magnus just decides okay it's time
to trade with Bishop character son f4
rook captures on f4 and now g3 pushing
the roof back rook to f6 and now d4 and
okay
d6 Wesley just the defense d5 pawn and
Bishop to d3 now and here the time on
the clock is eight and a half minutes
Magnus 11 minutes Wesley we have Kings
b8 an important move as you'll see later
in the game and we have kinked the a1 by
Magnus making room for the bishop on b1
and then now Queen to f7 now preparing
rook to f8 to have this wonderful triple
battery on the F file with d5 by Magnus
grabbing more space here preparing c4 to
clear the be 4 square for his queen
hopefully he could go for an attack on
the Queen side but now rook to f3 by
Wesley yeah this is the idea Wesley held
why it was important to get the King
away from the c8 square because here if
the King wasn't see it you would have
the very nice Bishop to e2 so now black
cannot play rook to e3 because the
bishop captures Bishop width check if
the Kings once it wasn't CH but here you
can just play rook III and now there's a
double attack on the bishop black is
just much better here you cannot go for
this as there is no check so after rook
to f3 Magnus goes back with the bishop
pushed back the b1 instead trying to
well if if the c4 is played in Queen
comes to before then you don't have to
be afraid of any roof to f1 that may be
coming with check because the bishop is
preventing that the situation on the
clock six and a half minutes Magnus
eight minutes Wesley rook to f8 just
nicely tripling on the F file and now C
for Magnus continues with his plan and
Wesley
doesn't want to meet c5 with the night
on b6 so he goes back Knight to d7 now
control c5 with the knight and Queen to
b4 by Magnus will be six by Wesley
gaining more control over the sea fog
square and here everyone thought that
Magnus was gonna go for c5 and go for
this series of trades a night cap first
night after CD capture stand the rook
captures the problem is black has Queen
to e7 here and now you don't really you
don't have a much better option than to
just go back trade Queens and play the
same game where you're you're you're
just worse the black's pawn structure is
better blacks pieces are better and well
your lights worship is just terrible
staring at that efore pawn and in in a
match situation where you have to either
win or maybe even draw to help you
survived maybe to win the next game you
don't want to play this
so Magnus decided for Knight to a5 I
hope hoping to create some attacking
chances but the Wesley says that that is
nothing he plays Knight c5 we have
Knight to c6 with check King to b7 and
here Magnus doesn't like his chances
Wesley can just well what's this
position is much better and you don't
really have a way of continuing this
attack you can't use the a Foursquare
for your queen you can't use the a3
Square for your queen the knight the
robe is covering that so there's really
no way for you to ever reach for example
the a7 Square and the Wesley can just
for example go Birchwood b7 pick off the
night and then just claim claim he is
better which is so here Magnus play
Knight to a5 check with Quinta a8 and
non light back to c6 and here Wesley is
a very content with the draw he doesn't
want to try anything weird so he just
goes back in b7 and here Magnus says
okay we're gonna draw this Knight a5
check King gate Knight to c6 and it was
in this position that the players agreed
to a draw so Game one of the rapid ends
in a draw and Magnus gets to fight
another day
even though if you put this position
into an engine they will tell you that
black is completely winning for example
after Bishop to d7 your idea is just to
pick off the night here white loses the
attack and blacks position is just much
better but Wesley's happy with a draw
here he says I'm not gonna push for
anything if it's you who
to push and then if you over push I'm
gonna take my chances and beat you like
he did in the previous three games so
that's a game one I do hope you enjoyed
it that we're probably gonna have a game
to up shortly I would like to thank our
golf a Paul Hurst and Joshua selling for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably with a game 6 of the
of their match or game 2 of the rapids
if you will so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your evening